[Music]
in 10 days
experience the movie of that
you will remember
forever
black panther will come to Forever ready
PG-13 November 11th get tickets now
[Music]
Maya sister would often say
[Music]
only the most broken people can be great
leaders
introducing name one was really an
opportunity to introduce another
Sovereign ruler of a group of people he
shows up representing telecon
he's coming for the surface World in
Marvel publishing Neymar was one of the
first superheroes frankly they called
him
the feather serpent God Neymar loves his
people and he's gonna protect them
because to be a ruler you have to serve
the people that's a deep meaning for me
is part of my personal Heritage as a
Mexican as inhabitant of a mesoamerica
finally I could find a more powerful
representation of my culture with
dignity and respect I cannot wait for
everyone to see talukan I'm excited
about how we're gonna see the world come
alive
both nations want the same thing which
is to preserve and to protect their
people but they're willing to go about
it different ways I need to move what
can't Place Another Life
is very much concern with what he needs
and what he wants this delicate dance
between the two of them I get chills
just thinking about it
call me no more
[Music]
thank you